in diesem haus im kalifornischen perez
östlich von los angeles soll über jahre
grauenhaftes passiert sein
diese eltern sollen ihre 13 kinder im
alter zwischen zwei und 29 jahren
teilweise gefesselt oder in ketten
gehalten haben einer tochter war nach
polizeiangaben die flucht gelungen die
beamten gingen ihrer aussage nach und
statteten dem haus einen besuch ab die
geschwister seien unterernährt gewesen
sodass ihr alter schwer festzustellen
gewesen sei man habe zunächst alle für
minderjährig gehalten
die eltern wurden festgenommen eine
kaution von neun millionen dollar
festgesetzt
die kinder kamen in medizinischer
einrichtungen über die hintergründe gab
die polizei zunächst keine auskunft